the biden administration said don't
expect much from the president's meeting
with russia's vladimir putin
and many say not much is exactly what
the president got
white house officials point to successes
including a deal to bring back each
country's ambassadors
after they were brought home earlier
this year mr biden says he told putin
that cyber
attacks from hackers by russia will not
be tolerated but critics say putin got
the upper hand
by refusing to commit to stopping those
attacks in the future
the president's national security
adviser jake sullivan was involved in
this week's summit in geneva
he joins us now from the white house
jake good morning thanks so much for
being with us
thanks for having me you you say that
the the summits were
unusually productive uh but the
president as we pointed out did not get
concessions
from mr putin on the issue of cyber
attacks
and cyber security so my question is
what is the u.s prepared to do if these
attacks
continue well first let me say that we
didn't set the measure
at some verbal commitment from vladimir
putin that
russian criminals would stop hacking we
set the measure at
whether over the next six to 12 months
attacks against our critical
infrastructure actually decline
coming out of russia and we believe that
we've set the basis for that
but of course as the president said the
proof of the pudding will be in the
eating so
we will see over the course of the
months to come whether this was
in fact a productive session that the
president spent with vladimir putin
on the question of consequences the
president was very direct
with president putin and he was direct
publicly he said that we have
significant capacity
and that we're prepared to use it uh if
these cyber attacks continue because
ultimately uh the president of the
united states is going to defend the
national interests of the united states
and he will do so
vis-a-vis russia if russia does not get
these attacks under control
are you talking about retaliation
specifically
well let me say uh something the
president said in his press conference
which is this was not about threats or
ultimatums
it was about a statement of reality if
these attacks continue the president
will have no choice
but to take responsive measures against
russia including in cyber
and he said that clearly and
definitively to president putin
and he said it publicly as well he's
mincing no words on what he's prepared
to do as we go forward
jake if you say including cyber should
we be stooping to using cyber attacks
against russia when we're asking them
not to do it against us
look what it comes down to here is that
the united states will take
every effort to stop criminals on our
soil from conducting attacks on critical
infrastructure elsewhere in the world
and we're asking other countries to do
the same thing but of course
if other countries continue to attack us
in any way
then we reserve the right to use all
means at our disposal to protect our
people
to protect our gas pipelines to protect
our water systems
and this president is not going to take
any tool off the table
in response if it is ultimately going to
advance and defend the interests of the
united states
hey jake you know it is a very difficult
task trying to protect american
infrastructure from cyber attacks
despite the best efforts
given that do you think it would help if
congress were to step in
and set requirements for american
companies to secure
our infrastructure to prevent the
inevitable
right now what the biden administration
is doing
is working closely with the private
sector in key critical infrastructure
areas
to get them to accept and apply those
standards
now voluntarily of course if it turns
out that that's insufficient
we should look to congress to take
additional steps
but the immediate need today
is for the private sector across the
board to step up its cyber security game
and just as we've minced no words with
president putin
about what we expect of him we've done
the same with ceos across the country so
you're saying you're unsatisfied with
the level of security as many of these
companies
well it is certainly the case that a
number of companies in a number of areas
of the american economy
have not applied cutting-edge
state-of-the-art cyber security and that
they need to do so because the costs and
consequences to the american consumer
to american working families is grave if
in fact
they get attacked in ways that hurt the
meat supply or raise the price of gas
or make it harder for americans to have
safe drinking water so
yes we expect better as we go forward
and
we in the federal government also need
to step up our game which president
biden
instructed from the day that he took
office jake the president
uh spent a lot of time also talking
about china with our allies and he
recently launched an investigation into
whether
the coronavirus came from a leak from
the wuhan lab why do we think an
investigation will be fruitful when
china is only going to show you what
they want you to see you know i was a
reporter there and they keep a very
close watch on you when you're when
you're in
in the country well there are two facets
to this
one facet is the intelligence community
analysis that president biden
asked our intelligence experts to
undertake that's a 90-day review where
we are scrubbing everything
we have in terms of our intelligence and
where we're reaching out to allies and
partners around the world
that will give us some more clarity
second facet is what you're describing
which is ultimately
we need access and the international
community needs access to
china to be able to get that initial
data
that will tell us the most about where
this virus came from
and how it entered uh into the world and
you're right
so far china has said no we won't allow
that
but we just can't take the no lying down
we have to continue
to raise the public pressure and do so
in a concerted way with allies and
partners
and that's why it was so important that
at the g7 the world's democracies came
together
to insist on a phase two investigation
in china of the origins of covet 19.
everyone wants those answers national
security advisor jake sullivan thank you
very much for joining us
thanks for having me